andrew garfield showing off some
spider-man style stunts on vacation in
italy i mean it's such it's it's a
character that's always gonna be so
meaningful to me and so beautiful to me
check out the actor going full acrobat
as he pulls out a backflip with the
assistance of his friend on a beach in
ishia yeah those moves look all too
familiar after all the guy did play
spiderman in a film or two well
technically three
i just did 80 of your job if we swing it
back to 2012 andrew gave e.t the
download on his spidey stunts which he
mostly pulled off all on his own i did
like 70 percent i've been told which
makes me happy yeah now fast forward 10
years and andrew proves he's still got
it which isn't a huge surprise given the
fact that he just suited back up for
spider-man no way home alongside fellow
peter parkers toby mcguire and tom
holland okay peter won peter two twitter
two peter pan it was just a really
beautiful thing to share together and to
find a brotherhood with toby as well and
with tom and and the fact that we have
shared
that we that we do share a very unique
experience after all the excitement over
his return to the world of everyone's
favorite web slinger and all the awards
love thanks to his turns in tiktik boom
there's not enough time
i went to three friends funerals last
year and nobody is doing enough
i'm not doing enough
and the eyes of tammy fay you know what
i'm gonna say god loves you
it seems andrew is making good on his
promise to take a step back from acting
to enjoy a little r and r
though we'll see him back on the red
carpet soon enough the evidence points
to things and to beliefs
that i have only ever heard whisperings
about his work and under the banner of
heaven earned andrew his first primetime
emmy nomination and when e.t asked
andrew about the whole taking a break
from hollywood thing while promoting the
show back in april well you've been so
busy but you don't have a ton on the
imdb page right now after being this
busy are you taking a break
i feel like you need to turn on that
you've got to keep it keep it hot and
you're going to keep it on the up and up
let's try and get some credits on my
imdb page
no one's ever satisfied hey can you
blame us
[Music]
you